hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up it's youth day at cop27
as the focus shifts to the generations
who will suffer most from the harm done
to the planet
anger directed at the increasing number
of fossil fuel lobbyists attending the
summit
and we'll hear live from the actor and
activist Lily Cole who's in charmel
Sheikh launching a sustainable fashion
project
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now we're four days into cop27 but
there's still a fair way to go before
the delegates in charmel Sheikh wrap up
for the year and potentially agree on
some meaningful action to help curb
climate change with the exception of Joe
Biden who flies in tomorrow world
leaders have now departed leaving it to
the remaining 33 000 or so delegates to
negotiate
today though the focus has been on our
future leaders and the people most
likely to be affected by the decisions
made in Egypt it's young and future
Generations day a day that's marked at
every cop Summit
well we spoke to one of the youngest
delegates an 11 year old climate
activist from India who you can see here
protesting against plastic pollution at
the Taj Mahal and she told us what's
made her such a passionate campaigner
I have one in many words committed a
small carbon negative state of India
barging Myanmar and we just pull up rich
Barber diversity hot spots but I have
grown up in the natural audition for my
schooling my life was set by cycling
titley in 2018 and Zach lompani in 2019
and after that I moved to Delhi in 2019.
again my life was missed completely
again due to the high air pollution
level and heat rape prices in Delhi so
all such incidents I have faced in my
young life turns me into a child climate
activist
well our climate change and energy
correspondents Hannah Thomas Peter is in
charmel Sheikh
very busy so excuse as well we'll weave
through the crowds just trying to show
you a little bit of what this is all
about this is the Children and Youth
Pavilion and it was opened by Barbados
prime minister Mia Motley who's a bit of
a rising star in the climate crisis
movement it's become a bit of a hub for
activism and we've heard from a lot of
Youth activists voices today demanding
Justice and equity in particular arguing
that they are the future the boat is the
future the consumers of the future and
they demand change now there have been
big protests too of course about
environmental activists and their
freedoms to protest and there's been a
lot of concern about the number of
fossil fuel lobbyists who are here on
the ground of cop27 are reportedly some
600 more than all the island nation
delegates combined but all eyes really
looking forward now to the arrival of
United States of America President Joe
Biden he's going to give a speech here
can you reject some momentum into
proceedings is he going to talk about
loss and damage and about whether or not
America is willing to pay into a new
fund to compensate poor Nations for the
damage inflicted on them by climate
change is he going to start to talk
about coal and oil and gas and phasing
that out how will he bring the Diplomat
diplomatic might of America to bear at
this Summit because I think it's fair to
say it still is in need of some momentum
so that the people assembled here and
there's nearly 40 000 of them can have
real hope that 1.5 degrees of warming is
still very much with insight
and don't forget you can get all the
latest news from cop27 on our live blog
just scan the QR code that's on screen
now
well let's take a look now at some of
the other climate news of the day and
climate Justice activists have been
protesting at cop27 today demanding that
the world's biggest polluters are kicked
out of the conference more than 600
lobbyists for the fossil fuel industry
are registered to attend the summit
that's up more than a quarter on the
number of cop 26 and hundreds of people
have gathered to highlight the murdered
and jailed environment and human rights
Defenders whose names were read at the
biggest protest at the summit so far
meanwhile back in the UK climate
protesters from just stop oil have
caused disruption on the M25 for a
fourth day in a row two people were
arrested for causing a public nuisance
and another five suspected activists
were arrested in a car with climbing
equipment and banners
water and fizzy drinks are now free and
food is half price at the summit after
delegates struggled to find enough to
eat or drink in the first few days this
has been welcomed by delegates in Egypt
who have previously complained that the
limited food and drink was being sold at
New York and London prices some have
even said that the move could help to
make meaningful agreement at the summit
more likely
now it may not be quite as visibly
damaging to the planet as a coal burning
Factory but fashion is one of the most
polluting Industries on the planet
garment and Footwear manufacturing and
Supply accounts for up to 10 percent of
global carbon dioxide output human
exploitation is also a significant
Challenge in a sector where
International chains of production make
it difficult to find out how or even
where our clothes and shoes are being
made
in order to address growing consumer
concern about where their clothes are
coming from the United Nations economic
commission for Europe has launched a
project for an international initiative
to enhance transparency and traceability
in the industry
well joining me now from the extreme
hangout at the climate Summit is the
model actor and Ambassador for the
project Lily Cole so Lily Cole lovely to
have you on the show thanks so much for
joining us so explain to us why you feel
that transparency and traceability is
such an important issue for the fashion
industry
I think it's an important issue for
every industry
um we're looking at Fashion but we're
also looking at critical raw materials
agroforestry and the idea is that these
learnings could be applied to every
single industry it's important because
if we don't know what's going on we
can't make choices we can't make choices
as consumers there's a rising tide of
greenwashing happening because of the
lack of information that's available but
also companies can't necessarily make
the changes they need to make happen if
they don't understand their own Supply
chains which is often the case and also
governments won't be able to know
whether they are actually meeting the
targets they're setting because they
don't have the data and the information
to understand the impacts of the
businesses operating in their countries
and there has been way too much opacity
for too long it's not a technical
problem it's arguably a problem of Will
and political and corporate will to
bring the level of transparency that
needs to happen to supply chains that's
so interesting that you say that I mean
the fashion industry does have very
complex Supply chains you're saying that
there are some producers who aren't even
aware of what happening further down the
chain is that what you're saying
yeah
yeah I've consulted for fashion
companies that want to improve their
their impact and they genuinely can't
get the data to go back to the beginning
of the supply chain when they try to
they can often see the first layer or
two so the factories that are maybe
manufacturing the clothes but if you ask
them where does the cotton actually come
from who are the farmers what are the
impacts on the ground at the very
beginning of your supply chain they
often don't have access to that
information and if you imagine we live
in a world where it's been shown that
Google can Google's algorithms can
understand that a woman's pregnant
before she even knows she's pregnant
that's how well data can understand
customers I don't think it's a technical
problem it's a it's a it's a problem
where we focus our energy and we could
get this level of data and information
so that customers can make better
choices companies can make better
choices and ultimately governments can
do the job and and regulate and track
the goals that are being set
and we know that there are lots of
challenges in making sure that the
industry is has less of a carbon
footprint but is it particularly bad as
well because of the frenetic Pace at
which it moves the fact that the fashion
drives change constantly
yeah I think that's a very good question
and that's the other thing I've been
trying to talk about this week is not
just transparency it's also the rate of
production consumption and growth GDP is
this kind of religion by which most
companies if not all companies are being
led by as a primary metric and they need
to rethink other kpis to also think
about circularity the dress I'm wearing
I bought second hand you know how do we
expand and extend the lifespan of the
the products we already have in
circulation if you look at the level of
recycling in Fabrics the level of
recycling and electronics it's
shockingly low and we really really need
to reform that very quickly to reduce
the amount of extraction we're doing and
the amount of farming we're doing in the
natural world so yeah questioning
business models questioning the central
position of GDP growth is the key metric
and looking at circularity feel
essential to go anywhere near the
targets we're setting and on that point
I would just say you know the UN has
called for all Industries to halve
emissions 40 five percent reduction by
2030 to say within safe planetary
boundaries many fashion companies have
made the commitment to halve their
emissions by 2030 but if you look at the
data year on year emissions are still
going up around the world and so there's
this huge gap between the pledges that
are being made the promises that are
being made and the actual data of what's
happening and the reality is we can't
greenwash physics like physics is not
going to be greenwashed you know so we
have to be really truthful and really
realistic with ourselves as individuals
as communities as companies as countries
as an International Community to get
very realistic about making sure the
pledges we're making are being put into
practice and taking the probably quite
radical actions that need to happen in
order to put those Pleasures into
practice okay Lily Cole very interesting
to talk to us to talk to you rather
thanks very much indeed for joining us
there from charmel Sheikh thank you
and just before we go a quick reminder
that our weekly climate Show with Tom
Heap is back and you can watch it on
Saturdays and Sundays that's at 3 30 in
the afternoon or at 7 30 in the evening
and of course we'd love more questions
from you you can scan the QR code here
or you can go to any of our social media
accounts and put your questions in the
comments and Tom will answer some of
your questions on his show
but that's it for today do join us again
tomorrow at the same time for the very
latest on cop27 thanks for watching
foreign